la toiture calciné donne une idée de la
violence des flammes des flammes que les
pompiers continuaient à tenter
d'éteindre cette après midi soit douze
heures après le début de l'intervention
les pompiers ont en effet été appelés
vers 4h30 pour un simple feu
d'appartement qui s'est révélé assez
vite un peu plus complexe à l'arrivée
des premiers secours
il y avait plusieurs appartements qui
était inquiète a touché le feu avait
percé la toiture et surtout des victimes
se manifestait soit aux fenêtres soit
pour certaines s'étaient d'ores et déjà
réfugiées sur les toits
donc si nous a obligés à réaliser dans
un premier temps de nombreux sauvetages
l'intervention était d'autant plus
complexe que l'immeuble et anciens avec
différents niveaux donc difficile
d'accès et surtout fragile dans un
premier temps bien évidemment des
sapeurs-pompiers se sont engagés sous
appareil respiratoire dans le bâtiment
mais dans un second temps au vu des
risques d'effondrement d'une partie du
bâtiment nous les avons faire ressortir
les pompiers ont donc dû intervenir
depuis les toits pour maîtriser les
flammes dans les immeubles voisins c'est
la fumée un vrai brouillard qui a alerté
les riverains
j'ai attendu les sirènes en fait à 5
heures du matin qui nous ont réveillés
du coup et
l'odeur de la fumée en fait qui nous a
réveillés aussi donc voilà prendra pas
plus grand chose on est resté enfermé
mon compagnon est descendu voir si on
devait évacuer ou pas l'immeuble
c'est la fumée également qui alerte et
bruce c'est pire est depuis leur balcon
en face de l'incendié ils ont suivi
admiratif toutes les opérations de
secours
ce qui m'a impressionné c'est l
équipement parce qu'il y avait 5 9 et 5
camions l'a1 et puis tous ces trucs
qu'ils mentaient décent et au début à
5h30 en voyait pas des flammes tout fait
et petit à petit ce qu'on a vu on a vu
des flammes à paraître et s qui est ce
que on a vu ses 6e monsieur qui est qui
qui était sur l'échelle et qui allait
aller vers les flammes
est ce assez c'est très impressionnant
l'étayage et le déblaiement se
poursuivront ce soir et demain
une enquête est en cours pour déterminer
l'origine du sinistre